let me quickly say that I've been a fan
of the Jerry podcast since first started
10 years ago
Joe's open-mindedness and just genuine
curiosity it was a breath of fresh air
especially to me as a scientist but in
general as a thinking person he inspired
me to be a better and especially kinder
human being so it was surreal for me to
be on there a couple of times last year
and I'll be on there again a third time
on February 3rd it feels like I'm
Forrest Gump somehow finding myself
shaking hands with John F Kennedy anyway
I also enjoy playing guitar and I
thought I play the intro steam plus a
bit more to say thank you for the ten
years of Jerry as a wise man once said
train by day Joe Rogan podcast by night
all day
[Music]
[Applause]
you